you crank so i'll think that we're
trying to set up some kind of lawless
garrison site
we're drinking beers in a prison gift
shop what the hell else would you call
it
military's found in a law and order they
won't let you out of boot camp unless
you square a four-inch fold on a bed
sheet
the law says you get open file discovery
and i want you to have
discovery that way when i beat you your
client will have nothing to hide behind
you sound very sure of that outcome
you haven't seen what i've seen
let me ask you i understand everyone has
a right to defense but
it doesn't bother you at all working for
someone like this
i'm not just defending him i'm defending
the rule of law
i'm very ignatian of you
i didn't know they studied the jesuits
in the marine
law school we like to fully consider
a problem before we blow it up
my turn let me ask you
what if you're wrong we're not
what if you are you built this place
you abandon all of your principles all
of your laws
and you're wrong
[Music]
you